now I want to talk about a very special
cameo there's a baseball scene but I
noticed a little adult Danny Torrance
Danny he's been pretty out of the
spotlight ever since yeah that's the
shining thank you only had one other job
after the shine yeah yeah but no he's a
teacher and you know he I stalked him on
Twitter and I think it really it really
was that way and one of the coolest
things about this whole job for me was
the day that he was on set I just got to
kind of ask him all the questions I
could think of about what it was like to
to be in that film I'm from what he
could remember he was so young but he
remembers a lot and his stories are
fascinating but yeah it was really a
treat for me to put a lens on him and
have him be part of this he enjoyed it
cuz when I saw him I was like oh that's
definitely him yeah it's really
something yeah was he hesitant to do it
at all or was he just like no he wasn't
he was happy to do it and he had he had
a lot of questions for me about you know
what the movie was about and how it's
gonna work
before he wanted to do it because he
tastes the legacy of that film very
seriously yeah and he was really excited
to be there I think for him he hadn't
been on a set and so long it the neatest
part for him was kind of react limiting
himself to how a set works right in in
an environment where all the all the
equipment is so different you know all
of the the tools of filmmaking have
changed so much from from when Stanley
Kubrick was doing it but the spirit of
it's the same so I think he had a great
time
when I was a kid I bumped into these
things then I was called at the shining
did you have the chance to meet him I
know that was kind of separate I didn't
and I really would like to and I hope to
see him yeah I would love to say hello
to him he's so amazing in the movie I
mean I watched the making of The Shining
and his they interviews with him they
are quite funny because you see him as a
little boy and in the shining is still
used to this blank sort of damaged
little soul you know that it's such a
relief to see him laughing and and he
was talking about he talks about
something in the making of which is
quite funny about what he's gonna do
with the money that he makes from
malarious that's funny
[Music]